i saw someone get shot yeah that's
awesome dude
tracy morgan was on that show and i'll
never forget
it it taught me about
uh the hood yeah and
and a different side of of what you st
it's just a completely different side of
life that i
that no college could ever teach you
there's nobody teaching teacher
when i'll never forget what happened was
i heard
and tracy morgan goes who got shot and i
went oh you heard the fireworks he was
uh i wouldn't fire him so he got shot
but he said it as as
calmly yes yeah and then he went oh he's
across the street oh he's struggling
and i still thought he was kidding like
he's played by play like he's out
michael suddenly yeah and look at this
guy can't even get another yard
yeah like oh he might get another brow
he's down
he's on the ground he's flattened out oh
he's trying to get back up he's up to
his oh he's down again
are these oh he's out of bounds man when
it comes to being alive this guy's
out of balance oh and here comes the
hecklers look at you now
look at there's nothing worse of being
shot you're
getting and now the hecklers come while
you're struggling for your life
for your life oh he's leaking he leaking
he's always getting hard and i'll never
forget the one guy had no teeth he came
up i
swear to god he goes you smeared it
that's like
you smell the smoke you smell like when
i was involved in vietnam you could
still smell the smoke
oh my god and i'll never forget
the blood is dripping over the curb
and and it's going down the drain
yeah and and then the paramedics come
like yeah you know so two jews walk in a
bar
i got a greek joke for you bro and still
they look at you
now yeah looky i was like what you're
like alright let's go back to rehearsing
and then a church choir shows up also
though for no reason
like it's just amazing dude
[Music]
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another
and you can watch this one you can watch
this one different options different
choices
some guy just brings you one option not
this guy
two options watch one this one or this
one